émotion toujours très vives rendez vous
au lendemain de l'assassinât du père
olivier maire ce prêtre catholique a été
tué hier matin par un homme d'origine
rwandaise à saint-laurent-sur-sèvre le
suspect qui était hébergé au sein de la
communauté religieuse à laquelle
appartenait la victime s'est rendue à la
police il a été hospitalisé en
psychiatrie dans la soirée sa garde à
vue va donc été élevé pour
incompatibilité avec son état de santé
âgé de 40 ans il était connu de la
police il s'agit du présumé incendiaire
de la cathédrale de nantes en juillet
2020 on retrouve en direct notre envoyé
spécialà sur place le cas les chais à
lucas bonjour alors on le disait le
meurtre du père olivier marc a provoqué
beaucoup de colère et d'émotion à
saint-laurent-sur-sèvre oui absolument
c'est dans cette communauté religieuse
des montfortains que le corps du père
olivier maire a été trouvé le suspect
principal cet homme rwandais de 40 ans
s'est rendu de lui-même aux autorités il
a indiqué aux enquêteurs où se trouvait
la victime dans la ville c'est la
consternation je vous propose d'écouter
le maire éric couderc que j'ai pu
interrogé hier sur la question tu fais
fassions pas ce que j'ai appris ça ce
matin par les pompiers les gendarmes et
j'y croyais pas quoi je croyais pas
surtout que olivier je l'appelle olivier
parce qu'on se connaît quand même depuis
pas mal d'années officiers hier à la
mairie pour faire le concert d'orgue
organisé par la commune
tous les ans et il était
il était bénévole à faire découvrir ses
l'orgue de la basilique
car c'était un organiste hors pair et
avec beaucoup beaucoup de qualités mais
en trop en plus celle ci où il était un
super organiste et il adorait expliquer
le fonctionnement cet orgue donc très
grosse plus que surprise parce que pas
forcément on s'attend pas à ça dans une
commune comme la nôtre quoi tout
simplement
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur est venu hier dans
l'après-midi pour assurer les religieux
de son soutien mais cette visite se
faisait dans un cadre très polémique
puisque plusieurs opposants au
gouvernement se sont indignés du fait
que l'homme faisait l'objet de plusieurs
arrêtés d'expulsion et se sont étonné
qu'il ait pu récidiver ce à quoi gérald
darmanin a répondu qu'on ne peut pas
expulser une personne qui est sous
contrôle judiciaire
il a pointé du doigt la démagogie c'est
son terme de ses détracteurs je vous
propose de l'écouter
certains ont cédé à la tentation de la
polémique la tentation de la démagogie
au moment où l'esprit le corps de ce
prêtre n'était pas encore en paix le
contact que j'ai eu l'honneur avec
l'église de france avec les prêtres qui
m'ont bien connu et qui ont accueilli
cette personne ici n'était pas de ces
mêmes esprits
effectivement je
il ne donne plus malheureusement mais je
regrette ces polémiques qui sont
totalement infondées et une deux buts
dans ce coeur de l'été que nous fait
renaître de la démagogie
je vais m'arrêter là par respect envers
la famille paré standard la congrégation
religieuse et monsieur est au coeur de
la république a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer
imagine aura l'occasion dans les jours
qui viennent sont en fait hier le vice
procureur de la roche sur yon a dressé
le portrait d'un homme qui souffre
manifestement de lourds antécédents
psychiatriques il avait été hospitalisé
pendant un mois avant le crime
avant de sortir de l'hôpital le 29
juillet et vous l'avez dit sa garde à
vue a dû être suspendue pour cause
d'hospitalisation psychiatrique elle le
cas légers en direct de saint laurent
sur sèvre merci pour toutes ces
précisions